mario buena tarde como code entonces la
nueva pregunta y cuando se realizará
esta consulta a la ciudadanía
qué tal pues mira en la consulta quito
como ya lo mencionaban los nombres de
los expresidentes y quedó muy abierta
quedó incluso diríamos ambigua porque
precisa en la pregunta está usted de
acuerdo o no en que se lleven a cabo las
acciones pertinentes para emprender un
proceso de esclarecimiento de las
decisiones políticas tomadas en años
pasados por los actores políticos a fin
de que se haga justicia y se digamos se
protejan los derechos de las posibles
víctimas al mencionar actores políticos
decisiones políticas en años pasados
pues lo deja muy abierto ya no se
refiere en específico a expresidentes y
podría interpretarse como cualquier otro
cualquiera otra autoridad del poder
ejecutivo raúl cuando se va a llevar a
cabo bueno esto es un proceso porque de
llevarse a cabo en efecto esta consulta
tendría que ser el primer domingo del
año 2000
es decir no no está próxima esta
consulta en caso de que se realice ahora
mario si los mexicanos entonces deciden
votar a favor de esta moción del
presidente obrador automáticamente se
procedería a un juicio contra estos
políticos y además le preguntó si
obrador podría ser también juzgado
bien en primera instancia la corte tiene
que devolver al senado de la republica
esta decisión para que el senado abra un
proceso de votación es decir no es en
automático que se realice esta consulta
primero tanto el senado como la cámara
de diputados deben votar para que se
lleve a cabo esta consulta si votan en
sentido contrario el asunto se archiva y
se da por concluido si dicen sí que se
lleve a cabo esta consulta entonces
tiene que dar aviso al instituto
nacional electoral para que realice las
gestiones conducentes a llevar a cabo
esta consulta entonces si el presidente
estaría
en este cajón digamos para poder ser
juzgado es abierto a interpretación raúl
porque al ya no hablar de expresidentes
sino de actores políticos que hayan
tomado decisiones en años pasados pues
solamente que se considerara su
actuación como jefe de gobierno de la
ciudad de mexico en años pasados porque
no está específico si se trata de ex
presidentes ex gobernadores en fin
entonces tiene todavía que llevar a cabo
este proceso en el senado después si el
40 por ciento de los participantes en
esta consulta dan su voto sería vince
delante y tendrían las autoridades que
aplicar este proceso judicial solamente
así